alors Roland Nadeau vous venez donc ce
soir nous parler de votre dernier
recueil un cadastre d'enfance alors
avant d'en parler plus précisément
est-ce que d'une manière donc plus
globale vous pouvez nous dire comment
vous en êtes venus à la poésie qu'est-ce
que ça représente pour vous je suis venu
je ne sais pas je suis venu sur tout
parce que j'ai lu et que j'ai eu des
gens qui m'ont appris à lire et à lire
de la poésie et qui m'ont donné envie
d'en écrire
on fait du théâtre parce qu'on a vu des
gens jouer au théâtre on joue de la
musique parce qu'on a entendu de la
musique ou vu des des gens qui ont joué
et on écrit de les romans ou de la
poésie parce qu'on en a lu et que ça
vous a donné envie à un moment donné moi
je me souviens que j'ai dû écrire mes
premiers poèmes quand j'étais en
quatrième parce que pour pour mémoire
vous avez quand même à votre votre œuvre
une soixantaine de livres je crois donc
pas que de la poésie on a donc des
romans des
aussi des comptes de la chanson aussi je
crois bien d'accord donc tout cet
environnement de la littérature vous
avez été inspiré par qui alors vous
savez comme ça
je vous dis ce qui donne envie c'est de
voir du théâtre et donc d'avoir envie
d'écrire du théâtre j'ai une pièce qui a
été créée là à l'automne dernier
des chansons c'est parce que j'en ai
entendu de la poésie parce que j'en ai
lu des romans aussi des polars également
les auteurs peut-être au milieu
forcément c'est à dire que pour moi j'ai
eu la chance par exemple quand j'étais
adolescent de rencontrer un des
fondateurs du surréalisme Philippe
Soupault puis André Breton un petit peu
mais Philippe Soupault je l'ai beaucoup
fréquenté donc voilà ou bien par exemple
mon expérience quand j'étais très jeune
dans une revue qui s'appelle qui
s'appelait La Tour de feu avec un grand
poète Pierre Bouju donc c'est sûr qu'il
y a c'est pas ça sans lesquels je serais
resté sans doute à écrire de la poésie
ou on ferait on parlerait des petits
oiseaux du ciel bleu et des cœurs de la
Saint-Valentin ce qui n'est pas tout à
fait la poésie contemporaine mais alors
dites-nous comment sans être
schizophrène vous avez quand même mené
de vie c'est vrai si vous aviez un doute
vous êtes homme politique donc vous
étiez c'est vrai donc l'influence
politique la littérature d'autre part
est-ce que il y a un lien entre les deux
est-ce qu'il y a des oppositions est-ce
que c'est constructif tout ça
racontez-nous alors
une anecdote enfin c'est pas une
anecdote ce que j'ai vécu pendant
longtemps lorsque j'ai été élu 31 ans
j'étais militant avant mais j'étais élu
31 ans
lorsque j'ai été élu maire j'étais mère
adjoint avant mais quand j'étais élu
maire la première fois
précisément mère 31 et vu et 20 ans mère
et j'ai présidé cette ville nouvelle
il nous reste à peu près 20 minutes
d'émission on va dérouler toutes vos
fonctions
de visite comme ça absolument énorme
avec Légion d'Honneur fessiers des arts
et lettres puis continuer en disant
abonné au gaz
quel était votre question d'Aurélia sans
être schizophrène comment vous mener ces
deux carriers pour vous résumer
chose un peu douloureuse à vivre lorsque
j'ai été Luère il était évident que dans
le milieu politique je ne pouvais pas
être un bon maire puisque j'étais un
poète entendu que les poètes sont des
gens forcément tête en l'air qui savent
pas gérer etc mais parallèlement pour
dans le milieu politique enfin dans
certains milieux politiques notamment
dans les milieux underground je ne
pouvais pas être un bon poète puisque
j'étais un sale politique d'accord donc
on ne peut pas être
des gens moi j'étais les deux à la fois
je pense alors être bon pour être j'en
sais rien ça c'est c'est pas moi qui
peut le dire en tout cas comme mère si
j'ai été élu réélu je ne sais combien de
fois si c'est sans doute que j'ai dû pas
trop mal gérer ma ville et pas trop mal
la construire mais vous voyez dans
l'esprit des gens voilà alors c'est vrai
que en même temps ce sont deux registres
différents dans la politique vous êtes
dans l'affrontement vous me direz dans
la poésie aussi avec les mots mais vous
êtes dans l'affrontement dans le relatif
dans le compromis dans dans l'art de
façon générale et dans la poésie
notamment vous allez plutôt vers
l'absolu vers quelque chose de plus fort
de plus spirituelle et c'est vrai que
certaines réalités difficiles aussi
parfois la politique
j'ai une cloison nasale qui a des vieux
depuis donc c'est quand on dit que la
politique est dure elle est parfois dure
même physiquement mais la politique est
un sport de combat mais aujourd'hui en
tout cas vous êtes vous avez laissé ça
derrière vous oui
c'est quand même si j'avais pas eu la
poésie je n'aurais pas supporté la
politique aussi longtemps voilà d'accord
alors on dit de vous justement que vous
êtes un maire poète on me dites-vous à
la donc elle est à l'époque d'Aiguillon
court qu'est-ce que ça évoque pour vous
je mets eu un compliment qui m'a qui m'a
un petit peu bouleversé c'est qu'un jour
un grand urbaniste m'a dit vous avez ça
se sent que vous êtes un poète parce que
votre ville est une ville qui a été
construite on le sent par un poète alors
je me suis demandé ce que ça voulait
dire et puis c'est vrai ça fait allusion
bien entendu à toutes les rues tous les
noms de bâtiments qui sont portés par la
création à la création de la Maison de
la poésie mais aussi quand on y regarde
et quand on se promène à une certaine
façon de construire la ville de faire se
rencontrer les choses et les gens
parfois de façon très inattendue et
d'ailleurs on peut rappeler que la
communauté d'agglomération a reçu le
label de ville en poésie l'année
dernière c'est la seule communauté
d'agglomération en France qui est reçu
ce label qui est un nouveau label qui a
été décerné en 2012 il y a en poésie
ville en poésie et dans ville en poésie
50 ans Yvelines est la seule communauté
d'Aglou qu'il l'est alors pour revenir à
votre recueil donc un cadastre d'enfance
pour lequel d'ailleurs vous allez faire
une lecture demain soir à la Maison de
la poésie à 19h donc j'ai un petit
extrait d'un je vous l'ai donné
d'ailleurs que j'aime beaucoup est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire
c'est une de parcelles voilà c'est un
cadastre d'enfance
et quelques-unes de ces parcelles je
raconte pas toute mon enfance mais
quelques-unes des parcelles bon bah
voilà ce texte qui s'intitule rapiécé
il y a trop de trous dans le temps tous
les enfants le savent
c'est pourquoi il les combles de rêve
il y a trop d'oubli dans la vie tous les
enfants en savent quelque chose c'est
pourquoi ils veulent vite grandir
il y a trop de savoir dans l'enfance
c'est pourquoi les adultes en ont peur
les enfants savent tout parce qu'il
devine que les grands ont des trous de
mémoire des trous de rêves et
d'innocence et qu'il ne les combles que
de vide alors dans ce recueil on sent
évidemment et vous le dites aussi il y a
une large part de graphie des passages
un peu sombres difficiles
pourquoi vous vous nous confiez ces
souvenirs maintenant
alors je ne sais pas pourquoi je sais
seulement que je n'ai plus écrire ce
livre à la demande d'un éditeur que
lorsque ma mère est morte un an parce
qu'il y avait des choses sans doute qui
ne pouvaient pas sortir mais on est
c'est la manière première si vous voulez
l'épanchement ne fait pas de la poésie
en soi et c'est de la matière Paul
Valéry disait très bien que la poésie
c'est 10% d'inspiration et 90% de
transpiration
c'est pareil pour tous les arts je pense
alors l'inspiration elle peut venir de
choses mystérieuses ou de sa propre vie
de sa propre expérience ce qui est là
est plutôt le cas qui est une souffrance
à écrire aussi
il y a une souffrance à vivre et une
joie à vivre et écrire c'est scoliner
comme un sculpteur se coltine avec de la
pierre par exemple le poète se coltine
avec des mots et c'est une matière le
mot est une matière vivante rugueuse
dure de temps en temps d'elle-même elle
produit quelque chose de beau et souvent
il faut frotter tirer creuser me
remodeler réappaillé pour que ça fasse
oeuvre est-ce que vous-même la poésie
c'est les c'est un registre qui vous
inspire moi je trouve que c'est
l'exercice le plus dur au théâtre donc
donc inspirant peut-être pas compliqué
certainement mais c'est propre à chacun
c'est tellement dur de dire des paroles
de personnes qui ont enfin qui écrivent
vraiment une partie tellement intime de
ce que vous êtes fin même si ça nous
parle quand on parle de rêve je pense
qu'on s'y retrouve totalement quand on
parle d'enfance on est de grands enfants
sur scène en ce qui concerne votre poème
mais vous savez j'ai vécu souvent à mon
âge maintenant j'ai quelques expériences
et quelques expériences des comédiens
lisant mes textes et à chaque fois
c'était une recréation selon le comédien
ou la comédienne c'était pas le même
texte pourtant c'était les mêmes mots
c'est un travail d'interprétation puis
chacun se nourrit est faite pour être
dite aussi en fait moi j'ai mon premier
spectacle professionnel c'était donc une
adaptation en théâtrait dense de poèmes
fantastiques donc une auteur qui
s'appelle Julie Proust Tanguy
descendante de Proust qui avait publié à
16 ans donc c'était des recueils les
avait écrit entre ces 13 et 16 ans brute
de décoffrages tu as un diamant brut moi
j'avais eu un tel amour en lisant ses
poèmes j'ai fait ok faut les dire faut
les il faut les faire vivre et il y
avait eu parce que moi j'avais travaillé
avec elle en montant ce spectacle là et
c'est vrai qu'elle a vu une émotion à
nous nous voir parce que on réinterprète
et en même temps à se retrouver elle
enfin il y avait une connexion moi je
trouve ça juste fabuleux je suis
d'accord avec l'or c'est très très dur
parce que c'est du c'est du mettre en
bouche en fait mais à travailler c'est
juste c'est juste du plaisir par contre
bon on va leur vous lire
avec plaisir donc on rappelle votre
lecture demain donc à la Maison de la
poésie à 19h merci bon restez avec nous
encore quelques instants on va
poursuivre cette chronique culture
est-ce que vous aimez la danse country
ah oui et ben écoutez il y a des stages
d'initiation du côté de plaisir regardez
ça va forcément vous inspirer ça
une piste de danse envahie par des
cowboys un bal concert organisé par
l'association cowboy adverser de plaisir
bottes chapeau et veste sur le dos tous
sont prêts à danser les quatre sept
prévu pour l'occasion au total 200
personnes réunies autour d'une même
passion la country
j'étais aux États-Unis j'ai vu les gens
danser j'ai écouté la musique et je me
suis dit je vais faire la même chose en
rentrant donc j'ai pris des cours et
puis après j'ai créé mon association et
maintenant je donne des cours je fais
des balles ça fait 7 ans pour la
première année l'association a fait
appel à Frank silver musicien et
professionnels de country et c'est une
passion et ça nous a permis de nous
aussi de joindre l'utile et l'agréable
ça fait longtemps qu'on fait de la
musique moi je suis passionné de cette
culture là depuis longtemps mais on a
réussi à adjoindre les
l'utile et l'agréable depuis quelques
années avec la country
l'association
proposition de danse uniquement mais
tous ceux qui aiment la musique la
musique country exactement alors sur
toutes les formes le rockabilly le Blue
grasse le outlaw donc plein de sorte de
musique country pour tous les intéressés
le prochain bal ouvert aura lieu en mai
prochain le droit d'entrée est de 10
euros